i want to start with
vera so in the conjuring 2 we got to see
your scene partner
sing an elvis song if you got to get a
musical number
in an upcoming conjuring movie what
would you sing and why
ready yeah oh no i'm not ready for it i
got a piano right here let's do it
let's go let's do it what should we say
i would first
opt to make it a duet rather than
a solo show the way he's like you know
the way he
the way who he got with i'm not a post
i'm not in fact
greg i'm not opposed to this whole thing
being musical for con
don't laugh p wills we can do it if
anybody
can do it we can is it like a sondheim
sun through kind of thing or is it like
a jukebox musical
what kind of tone i think there's room
for all of those
just thought of this right now what if
we do like you're
mrs love and i'm sweeney todd and we do
but we do it as
ed and lorraine in like a local
production of sweeney todd but someone
actually gets murdered someone slips an
actual knife
into sweeney's hand and we actually kill
a guy and it's like a whole thing
i am not signing up for that one will
not negotiate
it's hard to see you two fight but we'll
we'll get there greg that's
that's bs you just threw out the
greatest
musical theater composer and she
pooh-poohs it i know
the composer i i just don't think you
should write the next one
well let's give you a chance for revenge
patrick um who
would fare better do you think if we put
edward in atlantis
or if we put ocean master in a spooky
haunted house who do you think comes up
well no disrespect to ed
r.i.p i'm not sure uh he's
he's gonna do great underwater so that's
that's not going to go
that's not going to go i'm not sure if
his scuba diving prowess
back in
yeah i think i think orman in a haunted
house would be super funny
what would he do how would he like deal
with a ghost probably with his
his trusty trident i mean that's how you
deal with anything
yeah we would poke at them with this
trusty train
i think he'd be fine um for both of you
uh i love how much love is a strong
component of this film romantic love and
the partnership between those characters
to the point where we see the younger
versions of you and i'm curious what's
it like
to see the younger versions did you like
give them a crash course on how to be
you
they gave us cast approval of that we
actually saw their pictures like the
summer before
shooting it or i forget what the time
frame was but
several months and um we and we briefly
met them in the trailer
and really my biggest experience of them
was when i
watched it um and they
i personally think they knock it out of
the park
um i think this megan ashley brown
who plays the young lorraine and and uh
mitchell
hogue i believe his name is um they they
it was just i think so uncanny to
patrick
i think he just nailed patrick's smile i
think
these kids knocked the love ball out of
the park for sure
it's that they make it they get uh like
it just and it was like the most minimal
just expressions man they just make you
believe teen love is real
and it'll last a lifetime it's really
special
that's so sweet was that your experience
patrick no
okay yes no it was
no they were uh they were great that's
right i remember seeing their uh
yeah it was great it was very sweet it
was very
yeah you just edit yourself you did i
think you did
you just met them what's that what'd you
say
nothing i'm she pitched us like editing
it right on you saying
no hard cut to black sorry
she's on dialogue so she's a little bit
awesome yeah she has thanks so much just
to wind the internet every few minutes
there's a wheel off
awesome thanks so much for your time
great chatting with you all right good
to see you man